さんこんにちははじめしゃちょー
家今回は
初めて株式会社
代表取締役社長はじめ
社長です
畑のメンバーがついに3億円のお家に来る
ことになりましたはいそれに伴いまして今
まで3億円のうち結構人少なかったんです
よ今までいたのが俺管理人の大地君
編集スタッフの後輩あと形式がサーブいる
かいないかぐらいだいたい34人でずっと
いたんですけども
畑メンバーが全員来るとですね
[音楽]
多いんですよ人がかなり人が多くなって
できることやれること増えますそれは
もちろんわかってますよそのために来てる
んですから編集がこう進んだり撮影を
うまくいったりいろんなできること
たくさん喋ると思うんですけどもそれだけ
じゃないんです人が増えるってデメリット
もあるんですよ畑4人増えるからだいたい
78人ぐらいずっといることになるんです
けどそりゃ3人から8人に増えるとダビル
量も増えますしゴミの量が増えますよあと
俺が気にしてるのがにも今まで3人とかい
たら普通にリュック背負ってきてそこら辺
にポイって置いとけばよかったんですけど
もそのリュック23個ポイントやったのが
8個になったら
一応僕の家なのでそれなりにきれいに使っ
てほしいなというかある程度整理して使っ
て欲しいという気持ちがあるので今回なん
となんとですね
ロッカー買いました
ロカロカ
ローカルロッカーロッカーロッカーロッカーロッカーロッカーロッカー
全然できない人生で初めてロッカー買い
ましたすごくねもう学校にあるやつよ
[音楽]
めっちゃいいじゃん
すごくない俺の身長並みにでかいロッカー
買いましたでちゃんと鍵も付いてるよ
開けると結構
荷物入るなはいいい感じのロッカーを買い
ましたこれロッカー設置することで何が
起きるかというと
盗み合いが起きなくなるんですね僕も含め
全員盗人なので物の盗みがこの自分の荷物
しっかり入れることによってなくなるマジ
で人数増えてちょっと会社っぽくなるん
ですちゃんと準備した方がいいと思って
買いましたまさか人生で家にロッカーを
買う日が来るとは今本当なんとなく2階の
広いスペースに置いてあるんですけども
これだと絶対邪魔なのでちょっと
置き場所を決めようかなと思ってこの
スペースこのスペースの
[音楽]
ロカボカド感
ロカボカロ感
ロカボカドータロカロカノロータス
が人生で家にロッカーを買う日が来るとか
はいこの和室のスペースなんか首塚でき
ないかなと思ってここにこうロッカー
置きたいと思いますじゃあちょっと畑
メンバーみんなには内緒で設置していき
たいと思います
[音楽]
誰よりも一番喜んだら一番やけど誰よりも
一番喜んで終わりましょう
来て
[音楽]
ロッカー買いました
すごーい
何でこの真っ暗なの
色はどうでもいいだろう
[音楽]
いい
ですね
いやそうなると思ったのでまだこれにしか
言ってないんですけど今から畑全員に
サプライズでロッカー準備しましたって
いうのやるから誰よりも一番
嬉しそうでしたら
[音楽]
畑の中で
一番喜べたら1万円あげます
みんななります
ロックが作りました
けどまだ畑の誰にも言ってないんですけど
サプライズでロッカーやるんで誰よりも
一番
嬉しそうにできたら1枚になります
得意ですよろしくお願いします
というわけで
完成しましたロッカースペースです
買いすぎたなさすがに帰りすぎたわこれ
[音楽]
マジでロッカーだ246回買いました
かなり
圧巻だなでもこうすることによってさ
こっちの和室もさちゃんと仕切りっぽく
なっていいんですよねこれで部屋が1個
増えたような感覚ですないい
ロッカーマジで夢があるこれでみんなの
荷物がバラバラになったり何かがどっか
行ったっていうこともかなりなくなると
思いますもうマジでロッカーなんでね普通
になんか服もここにかけれそうだし物とか
貴重品も消そう
いいね
めっちゃいい多すぎたはいというわけで実
はですね
畑のみんなには内緒で内緒で実はこの
ロッカー
設置したので誰も知らないです誰一人知ら
ないおそらく荷物の置き場とか困ってる人
いたかもしれませんそんなみんなにこんな
素敵なロッカーがあったらどれだけ喜んで
くれるのかちょっとサプライズというか
内緒でみんなを呼んでみたいと思いますで
は行こう
はいはいみんな集まりましたねじゃあ
ちょっと10秒後にみんなで一斉に
ちょっとこっちの部屋入ってください
[音楽]
10秒後
[拍手]
[音楽]